y vamos ahora con las noticias de salud
y para ello me acompaña mi compañera más
Romero salamar un buen día para ustedes
Buenos días Ángela Por supuesto que el
tema que vamos a hablar el día de hoy es
el más importante de la jornada del
terremoto de Turquía y de Siria la
Organización Mundial de la Salud ya se
pronunció que dijo Así es Ángela como
sabemos los impactos son muy amplios
pero en la salud tan a corto como a
largo plazo tiene muchísimas
afectaciones y desde Ginebra donde está
reunida la puesta ejecutiva de la
Organización Mundial de la Salud decían
esto
la infraestructura civil y la
infraestructura sanitaria está dañada en
toda la región afectada en Turquía y en
el noroeste de Siria además la
destrucción masiva también ha dañado las
vidas de acceso en muchas zonas la OMS
reconoce la fuerte capacidad de
respuesta de Turquía y considera que la
región más necesitada de Siria a corto y
mediano plazo
importante esta diferencia abismal que
decían de la capacidad de reacción de
Siria versus Turquía por la falta de
maquinaria pero también porque no hay un
gobierno no unitario que llegue a todas
las regiones a eso la Organización
Mundial de la Salud anunció Pues que
estaría enviando suministros de
emergencia Como por ejemplo kits
quirúrgicos bien Ahora hablemos de cómo
es el impacto de un terremoto en la
mortalidad de la zona donde sucede si
además de las más de 5000 víctimas ya
mortales no que está siguen contando y
siguen aumentando y varios estudios que
explican que por supuesto hay una
primera oleada inmediata de mortalidad
debido pues heridas a los traumas que
suceden en el momento preciso del
terremoto hay una segunda oleada que
llega después de las primeras horas
después del terremoto por ejemplo pues
por los hematomas hemorragias o
laceraciones fracturas que no logran a
sanarse y que no reciben atención médica
y hablan de una tercera oleada son los
días posteriores que estas heridas o
estos problemas también faltas de
medicaciones pueden provocar pues fallos
renales a raíz de infecciones sepsis por
las heridas etcétera no hasta aquí
digamos en la primera semana después de
un terremoto como este pero los impactos
luego pueden ser todavía más a largo
plazo elegimos poner un ejemplo que es
el ejemplo de las enfermedades
cardiovasculares en las enfermedades del
corazón hay un estudio publicado en
delante en 2012 que repasa cómo se
desarrolló eso en terremotos anteriores
y vemos por ejemplo que en 1994 en el
terremoto de California aumentaron los
infartos en un 35% en las semanas
siguientes también ha sucedido lo mismo
con los internamientos por arritmias no
por taquicardias eso fue en China en
2008 se duplicaron los accidentes de
cerebros cardiovasculares Perdón en
personas mayores en Japón es decir eso
se puede deber por ejemplo al estrés al
shock que aumente la tensión pero
también a la falta de medicación y a la
falta de accesos de personas que
necesitan por ejemplo tomar medicación
para la tensión Y por supuesto Estos son
temas que no son prioritarios a la hora
de atender una emergencia como este
terremoto que acabamos de ver ahora otro
tema que también queda normalmente
desatendido es el de la Salud Mental
pero ahí está ahí está es una de las
áreas más afectadas por de hecho saber
que eso sucede nos podría ayudar a estar
ya tomando medidas de Cara a lo que
puede venir en el futuro sabiendo que
hay estos impactos no el primer impacto
suele ser una cierta insensibilidad de
hecho hablan pero luego emergen esas
sensaciones Dolores que se pueden llegar
a cronificar y a desarrollar problemas
más largos más a largo plazo hay un
estudio estadounidense de las out
Western Medical Center que recoge
también datos de varios desastres
naturales no solo terremotos en este
caso y habla de que un tercio de los
supervivientes recibirán en los
siguientes años un diagnóstico de
algunos problemas de Salud Mental la
mayoría hablan de estrés postraumático
pero también depresión o también puede
ser el desorden de consumo de alcohol
Suele suceder además en los terremotos
un efecto conocido como El Ojo del tifón
que es cuando más cerca está ante el
epicentro más afectaciones a la Salud
Mental hay y Cuanto más lejos del
epicentro hay pues más se atenúa estas
afectaciones no Además recordemos que el
terremoto en Siria es dolor sobre dolor
Hubo mucho supervivientes que cuando
escucharon el terremoto pensaron que los
estaban bombardeando que estaban
demoliendo sus casas Entonces es una
población que ya está afectada sobre
todo en Siria por muchos de estos
trastornos probablemente estas cifras
sean mucho más altas en los años a venir
Bueno usted estaba hablando de Siria que
es la parte más impredecible de todo
esta emergencia que puede suceder con el
brote de cólera que ya afectaba el país
sí los terremotos no suelen provocar
epidemias no suelen tener un impacto tan
grande en las enfermedades infecciosas
pero sí pueden agudizar acentuar brotes
o problemas que ya existían y es lo que
puede suceder con el brote de cólera
según el último recuento hablamos de más
de 84.000 casos de cólera desde 2022
desde agosto perdón de 2022 y alrededor
de un centenar de muertes vemos que de
hecho algunas de las regiones más
afectadas son it o alepo que también han
sido una de las más golpeadas por el
mismo terremoto no un desastre natural
así puede ser de hecho un campo muy
fértil para esta enfermedad recordemos
que se contagia a través de beber agua
contaminada y pues con la falta de agua
potable de higiene No eso puede hacer
que todavía haya más casos o más
contagios y también por la falta de
estructuras sanitaria que se ha visto
dañada también por el mismo Pues
terremoto es algo cólera es algo
relativamente fácil de tratar no con
solo lavarse las manos tener acceso agua
potable se puede prevenir esta
enfermedad pero Precisamente en un país
y en una zona como Siria además ahora
afectada por el terremoto eso puede ser
un verdadero problema todo esto debido a
las condiciones sanitarias más gracias a
usted Gracias Ángela